cool so hi everyone welcome to my talk
I'm going to talk about this thing
called Gaussian Pro progress which bit
of a pun intended is the most most
normal topic I could come up with and
Gaussian processes I think are sort of
this wondrous thing but when I was
thinking about it
the feeling that you often get is that
you know when you're a machine learning
professional you know there's so many
algorithms out there like this is this
might be your feeling on a day-to-day
basis and there's this pressure that you
might need to keep up with all this new
tech and that can be like really really
the motivating and this is what I want
to do now is this talk is not about
downplaying this feeling I think it's
just there but I do want to show like a
really really lovely hack and that is
understanding a mother algorithm many
many algorithms tend to share a
component and if you can just really
really understand one single component
that's being used everywhere really
really well then everything else might
become easier to understand and the
Gaussian I think is like one of those
core concepts because it turns out that
if you appreciate what the Gaussian
distribution can do then there's lots of
algorithms that are just much much
easier to grasp and this talk is an
attempt at explaining the power of the
Gaussian by kind of stepping up the
ladder of complexity of algorithms so
today I will literally introduce Gauss
and then I will explain the gaussian
trick for classification clustering and
outlier detection i will then show how
you can actually make neural networks
just get properties that might make them
better by using the gaussian and then i
will attempt to LiveCode a gaussian
process this will be tricky but I think
we will be able to manage that so the
introduced what Gauss is there's a bit
of a story about a preschool so you have
to imagine there's a town there's a
preschool and there's a teacher and the
teacher is lazy the teacher doesn't
really feel like teaching any of the
kids anything because the teacher really
just wants to do reading the newspaper
so what the teacher then says is you
know hey children please at the numbers
one until a hundred and that way the
children are busy doing arithmetic and
then the teacher can read the newspaper
and that level sort of the plan but then
there was one student who sort of looked
at the task and sort of said all right
this is number one and two and all the
way up to 100 but what I can also do is
I can just rewrite it I can take the
number one up until fifth
and I could take the number 51 back to a
hundred and if I reorder the numbers
this way one thing that you then see is
that you know 1 + 100 + 1 2 + 99 is 100
100 up until 50 + 51 is 101 and just by
reordering things a little bit 101 times
50 is a whole lot easier than sort of
doing old arithmetic with all the
additions so there was a student in the
classroom who figured this out and the
student once the student figured this
out the student got bored and figured
let's think about this and the student
said ah that's another thing I could
also do is I can also say take number
one open till one hundred and a hundred
up until one they also get like one
hundred one appear at the bottom but now
you got a hundred of them even though
you're interested in 50 of them so then
you have to divide by two and there's
also the same number and you can also
say does this generalize if I add this
all the way up until n can I still apply
the same trick and the answer is yes
it's the exact same idea but by telling
you this story it's a lot easier to
remember and then you sort of realizing
ah this is what mathematics is supposed
to do math is kind of like a compiler
but four numbers in a way and the reason
why it's relevant to share this story is
this actually happened and the guy who
were the kid I should say who sort of
did this that kids name was gaps and
this this story is actually attributed
to the guy who came up with the normal
distribution and the thing that I like
about this story is just like how by
thinking about this building block you
can sort of do arithmetic better by
understanding Gauss you can actually
understand machine learning a whole lot
better the one thing that I'm always a
little bit bummed out about by though is
like this is a really cool story and
this is inspiring and it helps you
understand what is happening but when
you open a math book or a book on any
topic that's like this they typically
explain it by showing you this dry
formula which is a bit of a bummer so
what I'm gonna try and do now is I'm
gonna go in-depth into this Gaussian
thing literally but what I'm gonna try
and do is omit this and focus on this so
that does mean that I'm going to sort of
ignore a whole bunch of details which in
the end are important but what I'm
trying to achieve here is intuition so
there's a certain shape this is the
normal distribution and the idea is like
there's lots of stuff in
Center and there's some stuff on the
sides but a lot of stuff in human nature
sort of resembles this in some way not
perfectly but like human heights there's
a sort of a Gaussian like distribution
and human weight tons of stuff and again
this is the shape this is the formula
but why is this useful well you know
because you can do some clever hacks
with it suppose I've got two of these
Gaussian distributions let's say that I
have the the height of people and
there's one subgroup of people with
distribution a and another group of
people have distribution B if I have
some person who has height X I then
looking at the distribution of the
difference of likelihood between one
Gaussian and another even sort of the
temped kind of a classification thing
and this is a concept we're gonna have
to remember you can compare two
gaussians to say hey if this gaussian
represents one group of people in terms
of height and his other Gaussian
represents another group of people you
can really compare the two groups for
looking at the likelihood and another
convenient thing that you can do with
the Gaussian is you can at some point
say you know there's like a lot of mass
in the center but the outskirts there's
like at some point this threshold where
we can say hey that's an outlier at some
point there's a there's a moment when
the point is so far away from the bell
curve you literally can't hear it
ringing anymore and that's also kind of
a useful concept so let's keep these two
concepts in mind and well I'll now sort
of try to do is just show you that with
these two concepts and also in higher
dimensions you can really solve most
problems I should say though there's
also like a two dimensional distribution
formula that's out there so to skip this
math what I'll just show you is how this
algorithm can sort of help you um when
you have a couple of points sort of in a
point cloud a Gaussian distribution in
higher dimensions essentially says you
know and in some higher space some blob
of points and there's some sort of mean
there's always some sort of highest
point and this can be in higher
dimensions what you kind of see here
right so it's like mu1 mu2 it's a little
bit of mathematical notation I apologize
but but this is the idea this is this is
something that describes a Gaussian and
I hired I mentioned now what's equally
important is not just the means but also
the spreads so like there's a spread on
the ax ax
access and there's a spread on the x2
axis right that's also very definitive
of a Gao share and the final thing that
makes it very definitive is this notion
of a correlation or sort of covariance
the the direction in which the Gaussian
is pointing that's also depicted in this
covariance matrix and and the idea is if
I have these numbers then I have this
shape well define and this is what a
Gaussian essentially is and you know the
correlation can flip so you can also be
pointing in a different direction and
you can also say there's like no
correlation whatsoever but but you can
express a Gaussian by knowing the mean
of the distribution about saying
something about its variance that
defines the Gaussian if you will so
let's see if we can use a Gaussian to
already make another algorithm better
and I'll just take k-means as an example
so k-means if you're unfamiliar with it
the idea is I have some sort of data set
and I would like to cluster it so the
way that this typically works did you
say ah there's probably three clusters I
want an algorithm to automatically find
these clusters and then the idea is you
start with a couple of centroids these
centroids will then sort of go out there
and look for its nearest neighbors so
each and every point is closest to one
centroid we allocate all of these points
to a centroid and then we take the mean
of the points that are sort of assigned
to the centroid and then we sort of move
the centroid in the directions such that
sort of in a nice little middle of all
the different points I know then the
means shift a bit you can repeat this
and at some point this algorithms are
going to converge and then you can sort
of say okay all the points that are
closer to one centroid belong to one
cluster all the points that are closer
to another centroid belong to another
cluster and there's a couple of cool
things about this algorithm like it will
always converge at every time you do
this thing the total distance between
the centroids and its neighbors the
decrease so you can prove that this
actually will converge but it's also a
very nice two-step approach like there's
one step where you say I'm looking for
all my neighbors and there's another
step we say hey given the neighbors that
I have I want to make like a good move
in the right direction
but this algorithm doesn't make much
sense if you think about it because
there's a lot of stuff that's if you
about it suppose that I have this as a
starting point and then I have these two
send
Lloyd's I mean sure what I can sort of
do is I can say let's divide them up but
for all of these blue dots that I have
here in the middle I don't think a hard
allocation to either of these clusters
makes sense because the idea is it might
be soft clustering at best but at this
particular point I think it's a really
weird idea to say you member of my
population belong to one cluster and one
cluster only it might make sense to say
now you can be like part of one cluster
for like 30 percent part of another
cluster for like 70 percent so how about
what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna replace
the notion of a centroid and just put a
Gaussian in there so what I'm gonna try
and do is instead of saying hey there's
a center of them sort of following and
all the points belong to it I'm just
gonna do the exact same thing but I'm
gonna be moving a Gaussian in this
sphere and the nice thing there is
because I have a likely a distribution
you know we can maps to some sort of
likelihood then maybe I can do soft
clustering I get some other benefits
from this as well and there's some texts
saying let me just say so the idea is
you start out with two gaussians they
can sort of be out there in space and
what you're then gonna do is you're
gonna say okay we're gonna sort of try
and figure out for every single point to
what the Gaussian distribution the point
might have belonged to and in this
example I hope you can see from the
Beamer but there's like a lot of red
dots those are obviously closer to the
red distribution into the green one and
there's a couple of bright green dots
which are obviously part of the green
distribution and there's some sort of
teal turqoise blueish adults sort of in
the middle we're a little bit unsure and
then the idea is that now that I've sort
of figured out which neighbors is sort
of associated what I can do now is I can
say alright then
using sort of a weighted moving average
if you would that's what I'm gonna use
to sort of move the Gaussian in the new
step and it's again just the same as a
k-means except I'm moving a Gaussian
around that's the difference and then
the nice thing is what you can do is you
can sort of move this around and then at
the end you can say hey again I've sort
of clustered my things and what you can
then do is you can sort of say well this
is one member that's not really part of
any cluster but this is a way of
clustering that also allows for
covariances sort of say hey it's not a
perfect circle while I'm doing this
k-means it's sort of a different shape
and this is basically k-means but in my
opinion just better and it's just the
consequence of the fact that you know
there
this distribution that we can go ahead
and use and and again this is it this is
the intuition is just this now there's
also a gif that shows how this sort of
works you can get this from Wikipedia
but the downside is if you really want
to sort of look for a Gaussian
distribution or this calling mixture
model if you're gonna go ahead and
Google what this is like and leave this
on the next slide what you're gonna get
is this formula and this formula and if
you understand Gaussian distributions
this is great because this is sort of a
deep dive once the intuition is there
you can use this to really fundamentally
go on the lower level to sort of figure
out what exactly is happening and how
this algorithm might be efficient but if
you're trying to sort of learn how to do
clustering but better and this is the
first thing you see on your retina like
not only is this gonna be confusing you
and demotivating you but it's also sort
of distracting you from what i think is
the coolest observation about this and
that is that this is hugely applicable
so what I've just shown you is that we
can use this for clustering right but
this has so many ridiculous applications
you can even make neural networks better
with this and I'm just gonna have a bit
of a rant on this so remember that I
said this in the beginning that you can
sort of say hey if I've got like one
gaussian from like one class and I've
got another gaussian from another class
you can sort of compare the likelihoods
and that way you can sort of say ah
might be more part of one class than
another one well I can sort of fit some
Gaussian mixtures on a class and then
using the Gaussian mixture model which
is typically used for clustering you can
also do classification and the same
thing will hold for outliers so suppose
I had this data set and again it's a bit
contrived but what I could do is I can
say I have some sort of group a I have
some sort of group B I have some sort of
Group C and then the idea sort of is
well take all of everyone from Group A
take them separate trade a Gaussian
mixture on that that will sort of give
us an impression of hey how are people
from group a distributed can we sort of
define that you can do that for group B
you can do that for group C and that
means that for any new point within the
realm of x1 and x2 you can sort of say
what's the likelihood of it belonging to
group Eddie what's the likelihood of it
belonging
- groovy and what's the likelihood of it
because belonging to group C this is the
one dimensional representation of this
this is a two-dimensional representation
of this and oh yeah by the way if you do
this you kind of get outlier detection
for free the cool thing is at some point
you can say you know this point is so
far away from any distribution of the
classes I've seen that I can simply yell
this is an outlier this is not something
that I can do and the funny thing is
this is a huge safety mechanism in
machine learning there are very few
algorithms out there that have a way of
describing look this data point is so
far away from anything I've seen I am
now maybe saying that I don't want to
automate this decision being able to do
that being able to say hey this is it
may be an actual outlier it's really far
away from anything I've ever seen it's a
really really convenient property and
this is just fitting a bunch of Gaussian
system data but already we see that it
can be used for clustering for
classification and outlier detection in
one there are very few algorithms that
actually do this and by the way this is
all probabilistic so if you're into
probability theory you get all sorts of
properties here that you could really
use and if you're into Maps because
everything is a Gaussian here you know
there's lots of convenient tricks that
you can do and the math is quite
solvable and the final detail the
Gaussian mixture can fit pretty general
shapes of data you might have to tweak
the parameter it says how many gaussians
and we're going to throw into the mix so
that's that's a fair problem it's a bit
of a detail but very weird and arbitrary
shapes can be fitted with this if your
data is sort of not linearly separable
this trick will totally work and I'm not
just saying this I actually implemented
this and so what I have here is an
example of the two moons dataset from so
I could learn and what you can see is
that I hope you can see from the Beamer
but what I've essentially said is hey
I'm just fitting a bunch of gaussians
here and once it's done fitting this is
sort of the likelihood distribution so
you can see that there's like some Peaks
here those are the peaks of the Gaussian
distribution if you would and together
they can form a really nice arbitrary
shape but once this is fitted I can say
there's some sort of threshold around it
and please do outlier detection and a
yellow point here is considered an
outlier any purple point here is
considered good enough to make maybe a
prediction
you can tweak sort of how far you want
the spread to go you can sort of tweak
when you can say it's an outlier or not
again because it's a probability
distribution you can quite easily do
this and another thing you can also say
well suppose if one of the moons was
from one class and other moons from
another class you can also get a nice
classification boundary and you can also
still work with probabilities and
because everything is again a Gaussian
distribution you can do math with this
stuff afterwards as well if you feel
like playing with this me and a bunch of
colleagues and friends and we even had a
guy from Brazil contribute to this
project now we've made this project
called psychic Lego and the idea is that
we just have some Lego bricks that
really fit well to the scikit-learn
ecosystem but that might be missing it's
kind of an opinionated package some kind
of sort of definitely as opinionated as
basically if me and Mathias agree then
we add it but if you want to play with a
GMM classifier or the GMM outlier
detector go ahead it's implemented we'd
love for people to use it definitely
have a play with this it is scikit-learn
compatible so it's not every day that
you come across an algorithm that can do
all of this stuff and I think that's
actually fairly impressive if not
inspiring because if you can just
understand the Gaussian then you can
pretty much already do half of what you
want to do in data science but these
days it's fairly you know hip and stuff
we should talk about deep learning so I
just want to show now are just like two
examples of how you can use this sort of
Gaussian mixture knowledge to make
neural networks behave maybe better and
one thing that you can do is you can say
how about I just glue some gaussians on
top of the neural network what will
happen and here's an example of
something called a density mixture
Network the idea is just some sort of X
goes in but at some point before the
final output there's an intermediate
layer where you say some of the output
nodes are called mu nodes and some of
the output nodes are called Sigma nodes
and some of the nodes are called PI
nodes the idea being that you have a mu
one for example that's a mu of a
Gaussian you have a Sigma 1 which is the
Sigma of a Gaussian and Pi then says for
this particular X does this Gaussian
have a lot of influence on the
prediction yes or no and by doing this
this neural network suddenly has like a
multi-piece output
there's not a single point estimate that
is giving it's actually being trained to
learn a proper probability distribution
not a whole lot of neural networks can
do this but by just putting some
gaussian sauce on top of it you get
properties that you might want now
there's still like numerical downside to
this approach like I'm not suggesting
this is the it works for everything but
just the whole act of hey I'm just
applying some Gaussian sauce to the mix
gives you properties to a neural network
that you might need and there's the
mathematical details another thing that
you can do which which I think is the
cooler trick you can also add other
probe list properties with a mixture so
take an autoencoder
typically what happens when you have an
outer encoder stuff goes in and then the
same thing should sort of go out but you
squeeze it down to a latent state and
typically what happens is things that
are different suddenly go into different
clusters within that space and if that
happens I mean one thing you can then do
is train a Gaussian mixture on that so
what you can do is you can say hey
there's this a bunch of gaussians trying
to sort of learn what the embedded state
is like if you doesn't sort of rearrange
what that means is that essentially
means that when the encoder takes
something and puts it into a latent
state you have a low dimensional
representation of a data point that you
can give to the Gaussian you can do
classification with that you can also do
outlier detection with that but what's
even cooler is you can also say hey
suppose that you know I want to sample a
I want to decode one of these circles
because they're all gaussians it's also
very easy to sample from it so it's
quite easy to sort of say hey you know
what I just want to have a random 0 in
this particular case could you please
generate one for me
and it sounds like a cool idea so I
figured I just built this and what I did
is there's this data set called amnesty
I use Emmis for this and this other data
set called fashion amnesty which is sort
of the same thing but for fashion so
what you see here are just some sample
outputs for every number I trained a six
dimensional Gaussian embedding and I
said okay sample from a zero Gaussian
and put it into the decoder and here's
some examples of stuff that I'm sampling
it's definitely not perfect but you know
close enough and here's some fashion
I will say I paid onyx yeah so there's a
bunch of shoes and at some point you
know I do want to mention it's not
really a perfect rendering but I'm
definitely on to something here
and there's like settings of the neural
network aging that you can tweak here
and as opposed to a variational outer
encoder what I like about this idea is
the encoder is just trying to do the
best job it can do in encoding and once
that's done then I'm going to introduce
probabilistic aspects it's sort of a
two-step approach that's all but another
cool thing about this is what I can do
is I can say hey how about I sample now
not from the gaussians but just from
that space there's gonna sample a random
point and when I decode that what comes
out is gibberish so this mixture that's
happening in the middle is definitely
doing something that's actually sort of
maybe I shouldn't say it's a manifold
because it's not the the sort of the
textbook definition but it's a manifold
it's it's sort of a way to represent how
data points are sort of distributed in
space so that that's a convenient
property and again the only thing I did
was I took a textbook out of encoder and
just put gmm in there and suddenly have
all these very cool properties and note
the shape it can be a non normal shape
in here because it's a make sure you
list try to fit an arbitrary shape but
again like a better algorithm because I
was doing something with the ocean a
final thing that's kind of cool and so
suppose you have all the zeros in latent
space if you're going to fit a six
dimensional Gaussian mixture on that
then the mean of every single one of
those gaussians might represent a
slightly different style because again
if it might be the case that the zeros
also have clusters within them that's 15
minutes
and the nice thing is by going over all
of these means you kind of also get a
glimpse of different styles apparently
there are a couple of zeros that are
more skewed like this and a couple of
zeros that are perfect round circles and
from an artistic perspective is also
kind of interesting is this kind of a
way of saying hey I'm classifying and
clustering and generating at the same
time and again I know of no algorithm
that can do all four of those things
besides this this sort of approach and
again the only thing I did here was just
do some stuff with gouges so we're
nearing the part where I just want to do
some live coding but before I'm going to
attempt to do that I want to
like one like which I think is the
weirdest property of a Gaussian and this
is sort of this weird meta thing and I
have about ten minutes to explain it so
if you have coffee now is the time to
drink it because what I'm gonna do now
is I'm gonna talk about like super high
dimensions when you're doing something
with the gumption
but I do want to already point out like
just adding some Gaussian sauce made
some algorithms better here and that's
it that's a cool thing but another way
of looking at a Gaussian is you can say
here's a two dimensional Gaussian right
if I look at one point from this two
dimensional distribution what I can do
is I can plot that in a different way a
two dimensional point you can also say
well on one dimension that's two points
and the only thing I'm doing is I'm just
making sure that this stuff is ordered
essentially this is just a different way
of representing what I've what I've done
here you know there's like correlation
here as well right so it's gonna be
really weird for me to sample an x one
over here and then X 2 that's super high
so so there's gonna be some if there's
correlation and this plane is gonna be
correlation on this axis as well and
it's going to be hard to draw like a
five dimensional Gaussian in sort of
this space but it's quite easy for me to
draw a five dimensional Gaussian in this
space the questions later so this is the
value so this is x1 has this value right
so this is the value of x 1 this value
that's the thing that's on the y-axis
here okay that was a good question field
that was a good question great thank you
for the good question but then you gotta
wonder okay so so how can I change maybe
this cuz this kind of looks like a time
series it feels like something is
changing over time right so this is
interesting and the main thing that you
can sort of tweak is what can I do with
this config ovarian smait tricks is
there something I can do with that
covariance matrix such that that
covariance matrix is forced to have
properties that I'm interested in and
how's about this what I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna look at the distance between
the points right so these two points are
way closer to each other then let's say
this point in that point so one thing
that I could do is I can say how about
this is really matter how about I take
the Gaussian shape I look at the
distance between two points I'm gonna
take that distance give that to this
Gaussian and I'm gonna use that
in this confusion matrix the question is
what will happen and that is something
I'd like to life code because I think
it's very hard to explain it without me
coding it so what I've got here is this
is just an instance of Jupiter lab and
what I can do is I can type numpy about
random dot multivariate normal and then
I can sample a multivariate point I will
just do is I'll just say I've got some
variable called mu which is just MP told
zeros and let's say that K is equal to 2
so this is a two-dimensional array with
two things in it and they're row of
zeros and what I'll just do is I'll do
something with like Sigma as well and
I'll do like NP they'll I give that a K
as well and then if I put mu and Sigma
in here all right this is this is a
multivariate normal and I just sampled
one point out of it that's the only
thing I've done here and what I can do
is I can now type ELT dot plot all right
and then and then you can sort of I can
do this a bunch of times but this is
sort of the view that we had before this
sort of the alternative view of sort of
a two-dimensional Gaussian and what I
can then do is I can say you know what
increase that so now sample one point
that's from like a 10 dimensional
Gaussian and it's got a kind of look
like this and if I do like 100 these
points it's basically white noise
because the covariance matrix that I've
got here that is independent so all the
different things that I'm sampling
there's being sampled independent of
each other but now how about I change
that so what I can do is I could type
for I in the range of K and at for J in
the range of K right what I can do is I
could say hey take that Sigma thing you
got there right I think that that one
part of the matrix and what I'm just
going to go ahead and do is I'm just
gonna sort of do something that kind of
resembles a Gaussian here so I'm gonna
divide I by 10 just to make it a bit
smoother but I'm basically saying this
should be the distance by the way so
that this is the distance between I and
J right so if so if this between xx
index and hundreth index that's going to
be huge and when you square that and put
that in the negative and give that to
the exponent you get something that's
very very close to zero so let's just
demo that
like maybe six points right so this this
is a different thing that I've sampled
but if I look at the Sigma matrix you
can kind of see that on the diagonals
itself it's close together has a high
number and stuff that's on the outskirt
has sort of a lower number well what I'm
going to do now is I'm just going to
increase the number of points enough
sampling let's just look what happens
suddenly this is it like this is still
super random this is a perfectly random
thing that I've sampled but there's also
a pattern in it a process and that's the
idea behind a Gaussian process the weird
thing is is if you sample a high
dimensional Ferenc of it one single
point can represent something over time
because of the way that I'm sort of
changing this covariance matrix but
here's the freaky thing while I can also
do is I can say how about I just you
know change this a bit and I look at the
distance between the two points and I
give that to like the sine function then
a single point from a Gaussian
distribution now represents a sine wave
to me this was super unintuitive when I
saw this the first time but by
programming this with just a couple of
lines of code I already was sort of in
this moment with ok I'm at least on to
something here so why does this happen
and I kind of made a picture to try to
explain it but the idea is if I have a
covariance matrix that sort of looks
like this then essentially points that
are close to one another they will
influence one another they have a high
covariance that's what that means and if
I have a sine function in there then the
high covariance is basically going to be
while you're going to co-vary with
something that is maybe ten steps away
and every ten steps away it is going to
be high covariance for it so by defining
I guess what people like to call a
kernel like the thing that I put in here
the function and I give it that will
force properties on the time series
that's being sampled and then I figured
let's do this in a really really meta
way so I've made an object here called a
kernel and it's just an object but the
nice thing about this object is what I
can do is I can say take the kernel and
take let's say like a linear function
and
these are just examples of kernels that
I came up with so this was the kernel I
typed before here's the function that
does like the sine wave I have another
function that sort of returns a constant
and I feel another function it just
takes a difference between two two
points now what I would just like to do
is just show you if I if I just take a
linear function like this like the
difference between the two points that's
what's going to define the covariance
matrix this is what it looks like and if
I take the RBF thing that I had and this
is what it looks like but the funny
thing is what happens if I say take the
linear kernel and then multiply that by
the linear kernel they get a polynomial
so the weird property here is by giving
a function that defines the covariance
matrix you can sort of force that the
covariance matrix takes a certain shape
but the function itself can be used as a
Lego brick because one thing I can now
do is I can say oh I just want the sine
thing to be added to the linear thing
and maybe I should zoom out a bit but
I'm multiplying Eric sorry this should
have been in addition my bad
but now there's like a linear pattern
being added to something that repeats
but the cool thing is what you can also
do is you could take that linear pattern
and multiply that by something that
repeats and then I get the seasonal
aspect that sort of changes amplitude
over time so the funny thing is you can
do stuff to these functions and they're
kind of like Lego bricks that sort of
have a cookbook if you will
and there's actually a PhD who wrote a
thing called the kernel cookbook and the
only thing it does is it explains all
these different kernels and how you can
multiply them together to sort of get
arbitrary shapes but then how do you
make predictions with this well that's
the weird that's the really
mind-boggling thing if I have a normal
two dimensional Gaussian like this if I
have an X I value over here then this
will constrain what values this XJ value
can take if my X I value is over here
the XJ is not gonna be down here there's
a constraint on that this probabilistic
that's something that the Gaussian will
provide for you but this will also
happen on this view so what you can sort
of say is suppose that there's this
point that's given then you can sort of
say well then that determines sort of
the probablistic shape that all the
points here can make and then as a final
demo
because of time what I've got here is
ooh Magister that I have this colonel
that I have made essentially and I've
got some data points that it's trying to
fit on and you can see here that I can
say look these are just some data points
I want you to fit on and if you're gonna
fit on these points I do want the
colonel to have like a linear increasing
relationship and something that's
seasonal well what I can now do is I can
say well I don't know about that sort of
linearly increasing thing but I do know
for certain there should be something of
a sign in there and this is the best
thing that they can fit but you have
fitted the best sign function here and
what I can also do is I can say just
take the linear thing which I like demos
they're plumbers wait I think I could do
this right yeah so you can do linear
regression this way so what did I just
do well I'm sort of running out of time
so but I hope I've just quickly been
able to do is hopefully I've been able
to give you some intuition on some
things that might not have been obvious
and that's that the Gaussian is actually
sort of everywhere in data science it's
this distribution it's a thing it's
basically everywhere and knowing about
it really helps out and it can be mind
blowing to sort of witness to fill
applicability
but understanding this mathematical Lego
brick really allows you to recognize
algorithmic parts and other algorithms
so if you're sort of being overwhelmed
by all of these algorithms that you can
learn one thing you can also do is just
spend an afternoon in a notebook
I'm really trying out all these freaky
things that you can do with a Gaussian
because just understanding that - like
it's full of 6/10 it's gonna make
everything else a whole lot easier so
this might be a better investment but if
you feel like you don't fully totally
grasp this that's like super normal I've
skipped a lot of details in favor of
intuition but what I hope is the reason
why I skip those details is because
those are the details are the things
that are really really the motivating if
you type in Wikipedia this is how
Gaussian processes are explained if you
go to a book and this is how it goes you
Gaussian process is explained the first
thing you see is that the Gaussian
process is a collection of random
variables any finite number of which
have a joint Gaussian distribution
square
no pictures or anything and if you read
the papers it's worse did you get these
you know algorithmic explainers that
don't really help you so what might help
it is this sort of thing that we might
want to think about mathematics is super
useful when there's context and
intuition but it's really downright
terrible if when it's just a bunch of
symbols being dumped onto your retina
and it's worse if this occurs here when
you're young but the best advice I have
here is when I was lucky when I was a
kid I was really lucky because my
parents actually found a really
convenient way for me to prevent this
intellectual paralysis from happening to
me so the story about Gauss that I told
you in the beginning that the very first
story I read that from a book called the
number devil and it's the weirdest thing
it's a book meant for kids it's meant to
sort of for eight-year-olds if you've
got kids trust me best book ever really
is still one of my favorite books it's
about a boy who's afraid of maths and
then in his dreams he gets a visit from
the number devil and there's all sorts
of fairy tales one of them is the story
about gaps that I just told you and if
you really want people to understand
like hey maybe folks on the intuition
first and then on the details there
simply isn't a better introductory book
than this everyone in my class that read
this book as a kid got straight A's in
their calculus exams and all my math
professors they just see this as a
pattern this book is something that can
really help you sort of gain is
intuition of what is actually a number
and this is going to help you a whole
lot thanks for listening
[Applause]
okay so any questions in question
questions yes here's one no thanks for
the talk maybe it's a stupid question
but if you go to the parallel
coordinates and so you say there's a
distance between the dimensions this is
this stuff right yeah so there is a you
say it looks like a time line but it's
if it's not a time line if the distance
between dimensions is not its arbitrary
so that technically it could also be
spatial you can have right now is this
one axis can also be spatial the
intuition still applies but then you
could higher dimensions upon higher
dimensions but the trick still applies
the idea is you have some sort of a
kernel that says given the distance sort
of between two points what can I do to
the covariance matrix such a day behave
in a way that I deem important but this
also works for higher dimensions I will
say though I chose not to discuss that
due to the serious amount of confusion I
might introduce this by doing so but the
distance is a interpretation and time is
sort of an easy explained thing but it
can also be other things at a time if
you're reading stuff on bayesian
optimization then that distance is just
distance in hyper parameter space it
cannot be random no I think so the thing
here is we're talking about maps so
there might be someone in the audience
who says ah I know a detail that you
don't so I'm kind of afraid to say that
but know that I would argue that you
need to have some sort of meaning going
into the kernel in order for a
covariance matrix to really mean
anything
thank you if you have a cool counter
example it come to me afterwards I would
just do that
thanks a lot for the talk I really
impress appreciate the intuitive
approach and my question is about slide
51 I think you have
specific but well done and just yeah
exactly the general problem I think you
said you have a sixteen gaussians or six
I have to count them but some number all
right sixteen so that's probably sixteen
I mean that is sixteen means sixteen
standard deviations and you've got maybe
a few hundred data points right so
that's a bit of a mathematical detail
but here's what happens for every single
point here I can sort of ask what's your
likelihood value right and because
there's couches in and there's some
likelihood value and this gives me a
distribution over the likelihood values
I can set a threshold there okay there's
a documentation page on the open source
package that explains this in more
detail but this is one of the ways you
can do this good question hi the
gaussian alto encoder business that you
did you mentioned very very quickly the
stuff half a sentence yeah yeah
variational all ten quarters this is not
a variational Alton color could you say
a little bit about the relationship of
yes to variation also the actual history
of this was I kind of figured like hey I
want to add something probabilistic to
my encoder and then I came up with
Vincent's auto encoder unfortunately
that name was already sort of taken
that's that's part of the story but the
idea the thought here is a variational
auto encoder changes the cost function
right so the steps that sort of the
gradients are taking are being
influenced by the fact that the center
space has to be a Gaussian distribution
note that I believe typically it has to
be a standard normal distribution so
another mixture it has to be a single
Gaussian that's what the variational
auto encoder typically does what I'm
doing here is I'm saying I don't want to
constrain the auto encoder anyway so
let's just train that and once that's a
given
then take that latent state and then
train an auto encoder sort of a Gaussian
mixture on that so it's more of a
two-step approach
I'm not adapting the cost function
whatsoever with this idea and I believe
this approach has merits to it there
might be some potential benefits but
yeah if instance auto encoder was not
going to be a good paper
okay any more questions questions
questions no questions okay yeah thanks
for the talk might be a stupid question
but you nicely showed how the sine
function is approximated in the linear
function
could you give more intuition on the RBF
kernel Oh something I've always been
missing not doesn't this talk so in the
end it's just a shape right and the main
thing to take away whatever function you
give it the one thing that that function
will do is it will make sure that what
the covariance matrix just behaves in a
different way an RBF stands for a radial
basis and it's just basically just means
it's kind of like a hump and I and
there's different humps you can do you
can normalize stuff you can add extra at
the parameters but the gist first and
foremost is whatever function you can
have it takes distance between two
points and then fills in the coordinate
of the covariance matrix that's already
a kernel and there's a huge cookbook of
stuff you could do so the thing is it's
not too important that you have the
exact right RBF it's more the general
shape that matters this answered the
question okay so we have one one more
question time for one more question yes
so yes for people that are interested
actually Google this thing called the
kernel cookbook this this character
David he's actually kind of clever he
writes about some cool stuff but he
actually wrote sort of a cookbook on
like how you can combine all these
different kernels what properties and
they have it's actually kind of a good
read if you're a nerd but but make sure
you get the intuition before you hey you
can you big movie to 71 so I'm only for
70 and so here you show that how you
actually take out the x1 x2 from from
the and but maybe in this the distance
between x1 x2 so this is a two
dimensional distribution which I can
draw a five dimensional distribution is
kind of hard to draw on a two
dimensional
but this red dots it has a very high x1
value and it has a very high x2 value
that x2 value is slightly higher the
next one so x1 is slightly lower here
than x2 is green it's the other way
around and blue they're super super low
so the interpretation of the values here
is whoops you can see the mouse right so
the interpretation of the values here is
whatever value I have here on the X 1
axis that's the value I see there and
the B value wants speak up and the B
value wants I mean oh and this vevo so
this is a value of x1 here that's this
value so it's just when I when I have
this dolet line here I have some sort of
value on the axis that's the dolt high
TC here the only thing I'm doing here is
I'm just sorting x1 up until x2 I'm only
sorting on the x-axis here the actual
value that you have here from here to
here this value that hits this axis
that's the value have here ok ok thank
you very much man since for the great
talk another round of applause please
[Applause]